[Musique]
tout un engouement autour de ça donc
pour cette présidentielle qui fait qu'
on en discute je sais que avec mes amis
voilà on est un peu pas anxieux mais
voilà on cherche encore sur qui nos
opinions politiques on se porte et on
essaie de lire les programmes mais c'est
vrai que ma c'est ça la fois excitant et
à la fois
oui à la fois angoissant
[Musique]
c'est donc comme un fonctionnement
tender on va pouvoir donc ce que les
soit donc à gauche pour refuser la
proposition ou soit scrollé à droite
pour pouvoir valider la proposition si
on est d'accord avec ce qu'ils proposent
concrètement je pense que ça va m'aider
parce que encore un vrai flou parmi mes
choix mais je sais en tout cas dans quel
voilà donc l valeurs je vais me
retrouver
je trouve que cette application sert
surtout à te renseigner plus précisément
sur ce que pense chacun des candidats
mais complique entre guillemets ton
choix final
je pense que aux prochaines élections je
vais faire le même vote que j'ai fait il
ya cinq ans l'application va pas changer
grand chose
c'est gelé plus pris comme un loisir
comme chose de ludique
[Musique]
dans les quelques pays où il ya eu des
études ou les gens utilisaient beaucoup
ce genre d'application n'a pas vu que ça
avait une incidence sur sur sur les
votes ce qui est assez compréhensible un
d'ailleurs mais bon il peut y avoir un
petit effet positif de d'intéressement
de recherche d'informations et puis de
centrer davantage la campagne sur les
questions de deux programmes
[Musique]
ils sont obligés comme tout le monde de
respecter un certain nombre de choses
s'il ya des données personnelles c'est à
dire qui vous identifient relatives à
vos opinions politiques il faut qu'il ya
une exigence de consentement quand vous
explique clairement l'utilisation des
données il ya souvent aussi en principe
de finalité c'est à dire que si c'est
par exemple pour la campagne électorale
on peut pas utiliser les données au delà
la compagne électorale
[Musique]